each member of the winning team takes
home
a hundred dollars i could really use
that money
i've been saving up for one of those 3d
ultrasounds you know the one where the
baby's all like
and the best part is that the red team
doesn't even know about
the money jonah i'm sorry i just i
i don't i i am a little uncomfortable uh
pushing people to buy things that they
don't want or not seriously
i will kill myself before i go back to
2d ultrasound okay
i will kill myself withdraw
okay i need to volunteer oh right here
at first pick me
okay thank you mateo who else
anyone
garrett yeah i just wanted to say no
you're all in greats
i hope someone sets you all on fire and
you need a volunteer to put it out it's
too much for 6 amd i don't think it's
enough
okay fine i'll i'll do it okay thank you
jonah
uh you and mateo will be in charge of
our in-store dog
adoption today yes that's right the
volunteer job was desirable that was a
lesson
hello the samaritan as he traveled
came to where six am gwen okay right but
anyway while the rest of you are having
normal dogless days
these two selfless heroes will be in
puppy heaven
i want to be in puppy heaven i'll switch
if anybody wants i don't really care
about dogs
i mean i don't dislike them i just you
know i don't really have strong feelings
one way or the other
you're a psychopath sociopath he's a
sociopath is it because they don't like
you
no no i think it it says something about
our priorities that we spend so
much money on pets when there are
literally millions of children without
adequate nutrition
i hope you die funny i've never been uh
never been assigned here
before jewelry's a real can of worms in
terms of feminism you know
uh-huh
here we go this is the super bowl
of retail there's a buzz
in the air a charge that probably
doesn't read on camera
uh but over here we have the pre-opening
potluck
every employee brings a dish much in the
spirit of
sharing isn't that a delightful
tradition amy yeah i love waking up at
3am to eat sandra's cold spinach
casserole
it's meant to be served cold sorry okay
garrett any advice for my first black
friday
get that camera out my face all right
not a morning person
jonah so the red team knows about the
money now
so it's time for the gold team to stop
pussyfooting around
i'm not doing that with my feet i just
have trouble pressuring people into
buying stuff they don't need well that's
selfish actually i think it's the
opposite of selfish
just keep it on the dl all right i got
you son oh god don't say that
pretend i'm not here why pretend when
you could really just not
be here wow pretty tough on her i feel
like
i barely did anything my first day yeah
we all felt that way
what about sexual co-workers awful
just say you don't care
this is nice huh taking a well-earned
break with my co-workers
i feel like i'm finally fitting in here
you don't get to decide when you're
fitting and we'll let you know
i'm just saying getting used to it
not getting used to standing all day
it's not a problem i have to deal with
yeah well
lucky you my friend
not luck lucky not lucky you that's i
don't think you're lucky so you think
i'm unlucky
not well you know what i mean that's
that's an it's an expression why don't
you just
eject right now you know it's so weird
that your feet hurt because every time i
see you i feel like you're sitting
try doing this job six months pregnant
yeah seriously
that's brutal i didn't know you're
pregnant too i was when i was 19
then i gave birth to my daughter so i'm
not pregnant now but thank you for
thinking so i didn't mean you look
pregnant i just been inject i deject i
didn't know that you had a child i
listen that's i think that's beautiful
really i i'm in awe of single mothers
so i'm married oh
you should have just ejected man why are
you in awe of single mothers
i just think it's it's very brave to
have a child especially at your age
well i didn't set out to have a baby
came from sex
right sure uh but but you you
bravely made the decision to go through
with it well i couldn't get a ride to
planned parenthood well if you ever need
one in the future
jonah i'd prefer if you didn't offer to
shuttle our employees to the abortion
clinic no i meant rides in general what
if it was just for a pap smear could i
get a ride for that
they recommend one a year but i like to
go extra make sure everything's
up to code okay i'm just gonna say it
i'm fine with you driving your
co-workers anywhere
except the abortion clinic damn it glenn
you cannot talk about your personal
feelings on abortion in the workplace i
didn't bring up
abortion he can't that's not technology
i'm recording this entire conversation
abortion abortion abortion abortion
abortion you dug your own grave
we can't afford a grill right now but we
can afford for you to take all the
college classes in the world
excuse me this is not adam's fault this
is my fault
stay out of this hey uh you know why
they call it
black friday we really don't have to
make conversations okay cool we can just
yeah just quiet okay yeah yeah see
latino parents are different
we don't really need our kids to like us
we just break their spirits so the world
doesn't
huh and why why do you pierce your
baby's ears
not on a panel got it i'll just find out
on reddit
trust me you do not want to have the day
that i'm having they they keep like
like thrusting their pelvises and
calling me j
bone you have a nickname i didn't get a
nickname i feel like you're missing the
point
if you're j-bone then i want to be a
whole you sure
obviously not see you around a-hole
shut up so how'd you guys meet
i don't really want to talk about my
home life got it
this is the dark night of our souls
a portrait of hopelessness
wow you can't just keep us here i'm
going trick-or-treating with my daughter
yeah i have a date
with a good book i'm going to a
screening of nosferatu at the tivoli if
anybody wants to come
wow that sounds really terrible guys
okay amy not guys this is what black
friday wants
that is a family recipe we have a secret
ingredient
but this is not what black friday is
gonna get
oh cinnamon boring and we are gonna
overcome this
because there's everything could you
please shut
up you're an intense mom i do not want
to be around when emma starts dating
why would you even mention that
incidentally i'm i'm brexit how has
nobody asked me about that all day
long talk to you for a second it's kind
of personal yeah sure
sure okay well first of all you need to
calm down i'm calm
calm just you know my roomie's coming to
me for a little heart-to-heart it's a
it's a good day it's a really it's a
really good day basically dina and i
decided together to break up and now
she's going around she's telling
everybody that she dumped me which is
not true it was mutual
can you stop active listening oh yes
sorry continue
and i feel like i want to let everyone
know but
dean is in a rough place and i don't
want it to look like i'm kicking her
when she's down got it okay so
let's unpack this uh it sounds to me
like you're looking for a way to let
everybody know
what happened with you and dina without
it reflecting poorly
on you that's exactly what i just said
okay
that's a toughie that is a tough tough
token okay this is a good word
you